hello everyone it seems like this a
World Cup 2017 in Tbilisi Georgia has
been going on forever and well even the
final round has been going on pretty
long in the final round eleven Iranian
is playing against Dingley rim and as
they drew all their classical games they
had to to rapid games for the tie breaks
and well in this game I will show you
where eleven Ariane was playing with the
white pieces and I will put a link in
the description below where eleven had
the black pieces so you can check out
that game as well as I kind of preferred
this game with white it's a very
tactical game and well it seems all that
bughouse
sorry has been playing is really paying
off but before I show you the game one
fun fact about ding Liron if you know if
you remember my brother-in-law is out of
he actually played about 100 100 games
again stating leerin on this website
called chess dome or chess arena
something like that and once i came to
that website and I said I sent a game
requesting leerin and he accepted and he
sorry we play the game I had the white
pieces and we played the Kings gambit
and Tingler and resigned to the game but
he resigned
only to show me how to play this line of
the Kings gambit that I was playing and
it was a it was a very instructive and
fun line so a very cool guy Dingley and
definitely but that being said let's see
this game so Ariane is white and ding
Lorraine is black we have c4 Knight to
f6 Knight to f3 and east six Knight to
c3
D 5 D for c6 and the Bishop to g5 we
have h6 Bishop captures on f6 Queen
captures on f6 and Queen to b3 the
Hastings variation of the semi Slav we
have a knife to d7 now e4 d captures on
e4 Knight captures on e4 Queen to f4 and
Bishop to d3
and we have E 5 biting Liron and here
are long castles and we have ECAP the
sword Bishop to e7 first rook a to e 1
and E captures on d4 and well in in this
position Ireland can capture this d4
pawn it's not really a problem but he
has he has a better idea for a rapid
game he plays a bishop to be one with
ideas of one black castles playing Queen
to d3 and going for that early checkmate
threat
so earlier in castles we have united to
g3 Bishop to d8 and getting away from
this rook anyone and now Queen to d3
already this is move 15 and the 11 is
threatening checkmate on h7 so Lee says
that we stopped g6 and here we have an
Ireland signature move he plays h4 and
well can you capture this pawn with the
bishop it I mean it'd be pretty useful
if you could but you can't if Bishop
captures on h4 you get rook to e4 and
you lose the bishop or if you don't want
to lose the bishop you have to play
something like backup capture some g3
and give up the Queen for rock and the
piece after rook after some Bishop
captures but of course Tingler wasn't
interested in this so after h4 we have
nice to have six and now h5 sorry about
that of course part of the point cannot
be captured as if this g / g po never
moves well Knight will capture and then
Queen to h7 is is a threat again so we
have g5 Knight to e5
we have Bishop to a5 now attacking this
rook anyone and now a beautiful idea by
LaVon
we have Knight to g6 attacking both the
Queen and the rook and can this not be
captured
well if F captures on g6 simply Queen
captures on g6 with check King to h8 and
rook to e7 and there is no defense
against Queen to g7 checkmate if you try
and defend it for example with well if
you try 98 then you get Queen h7 if you
try Rob g8 and simply Queen captures on
H
like blocks in the rug here is checkmate
and well after this Knight to g6 Tingler
and of course doesn't capture the night
he plays Queen to d2 we have 97 with
check King to g7 and now Queen to b3
eridan doesn't want to trade Queens and
well he plays Queen to b3 we have Queen
back to a4 nabis Bishop is again
attacking the rook anyone and now rook
to d1 we have Bishop to b6 right G to f5
with check Bishop captures light
scatters with check came to h8 and now
g3 Queen to g4 and now Knight captures
and h6
I would attempt on the Queen we have
Queen to h5 keep the g2 and you can't
capture the night if Queen captures them
rock to h1 pinning the Queen and even
even if you block with night night to h5
come to f3
this is waiting for white so after King
to g2 we have d3 blocking the white
bishop and also activating this dark
squared Bishop Quinta c3 now attacking
this knight on f6 King to the g7
defending we have Knight to f5 with
check King to G King to g6 and now rook
to h1 sorry that flu still has the
better of me and in this position after
rook to h1 and England resign the game
because well you can't really do
anything if you try and save the Queen
for example with Queen to g4 you get a
rock to h6 with check and after King
captures on f5 rook captures on f6 would
check King to e4 and Bishop captures on
v3 and this is checkmate
solid England didn't go for this after
rook to h1 dealer and resigned the game
and 11 Aragon one one tournament that is
said to be the hardest tournament to win
and that is the World Cup 2017 so yeah
good game 11
that's it I would like to thank roll de
Silva for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and hopefully I will
see you soon